all right moving to sports the raiders
were back at home after two weeks on the
road the silver and black entering
must-win territory john
as the nfl playoff picture begins to
take shape take it away yeah thank you
sasha being told you've been relieved of
your duties is certainly cold but that's
what happens when the colts cold clock
your defense
entering this week it was get better or
else today the else was revealed the
raiders have fired defensive coordinator
paul gunther the colts making their
maiden voyage to
las vegas for business purposes and they
were good at business raiders down 10-0
first
but come alive derek carter foster
moreau and
moreau on the go he can't be stopped
47-yard touchdown his first of the
season just fourth catch
second quarter sound the aguilar alarm
that's car
to nelson agler another touchdown las
vegas seizes the lead
but in the hospitality capital of the
world t-y hilton has a say
phillip rivers goes a long form to the
abbreviation t-y
20-14 the score half second half defense
and confidence
not pictured jonathan taylor running
like he's back at the university of
wisconsin 62-yard touchdown
colts ran for 212 yards and threw for
another 244 raider nation desperation
worked last week but the jets can't be
on the schedule every week
interception kari willis 53 yards he'll
turn the lights out when he leaves
44-27 raiders fall to seven and six
possibly we had no answer
you can't give up that many yards
rushing and not get to the quarterback
and then lose the turnover marsh
margin and expect to win in this league
we got stuck on some blocks
uh we misfit some runs and uh we paid
for it
big time but we had no answer today
and we better find some answers and as
soon as i'm done here we'll start
searching
one of those answers was to fight the
defensive coordinator and another one
was changing the defensive play caller
71 year old defensive line coach rod
marinelli will assume control
of one of the league's most
disappointing units sasha